Bruno loro bonjour une question pour
commencer quelle fonction occupera
jean-v LeDrian en 2016 ministre de la
Défense ou président de la Région
Bretagne c'est un débat qui qui
ressurgit cette semaine alors si on s'en
tient à la règle du non cumule entre un
poste de ministre et un mandat dans un
exécutif local qui a été mise en vigueur
en 2012 il va devoir faire un choix à
moins qu'il puisse profiter d'une
dérogation et qu'il puisse mener de font
les les deux les deux missions Mar
marieise Lebranchu qui est l'autre
ministre bretonne du gouvernement y est
favorable qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous non moi je pense qu'il ne peut pas
y avoir de ministres qui soi en charge
d'une collectivité que c'est que le
premier ministre et le président de la
République stri de la règle oui ils ne
l'accepteront bien entendu pas et donc
le souhait que je forme pour 2016 c'est
que jean-v ledriillant reste ministre de
la Défense et que nous ayons en décembre
2015 conservé la région Bretagne donc
vous ne souhaitez pas qu'il mène la la
campagne en tête de liste en
région-bretagne je pense que jean-v
ledriillant est assez identifié pour
être présent dans cette campagne sans
être en position de devenir président de
la région mais c'est à lui de le dire il
l'annoncera je pense dans quelques jours
mais ce que je souhaite bien entendu
c'est qu'il puisse continuer à apporter
vous savez
l'effet de sa diplomatie de sa capacité
à comprendre de sa capacité à agir vous
êtes proche de de Jean ledri vous av
fait par cette décision
non je pense que sur un sujet comme ça
il en discutera jusqu'au dernier moment
avec le président de la République
est-ce que vous connaissez Bruno lerou
le film Un jour sans fin avec Bill Meray
oui c'est un film des années 90 c'est
l'histoire de de d'un homme qui vit
chaque jour la même journée encore et
encore ce personnage ça pourrait
peut-être être un peu vous dans le rôle
du patron des députés PS à l'Assemblée
il y a un an vous écriviez aux députés
pour pour les convaincre de de voter le
budget il s'était finalement abstenu je
parle des députés frondeur un an plus
tard on a l'impression que situation est
un peu la même Laurent baomel encore
cette semaine dit sir Ren bouge il sera
difficile de de voter le budget vous
êtes pas un peu lassé et vous vous
rendez compte le budget ça revient
chaque année comme Noël et le nouvel an
ou ou quel problème mais toujours la
même chaque année et chaque année être
obligé je parle pas du budget je parle
de la Fronde mais moi je la fronde vous
savez moi j'ai dit à chacun de prendre
ses responsabilités et j'ai dit au
frondeur depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois que j'étais prêt à toute discussion
avec eux mais qu'il n'empêcheraiit
jamais aucun texte de passé qu'il ne
pourrait pas se mettre en travers de la
majorité et la majorité elle s'exprime
au sein du groupe
288 députés aujourd'hui quand on parle
des frondeurs on parle de 20 à 30 de mes
collègues ça on met quand même 250 de
l'autre côté on en a entendu un certain
nombre tout à l'heure et donc le budget
sera voté ce que je leur dis simplement
c'est que cette année il y a peut-être
une différence par rapport à l'année
dernière c'est que nous sommes aussi en
campagne régionale et qu'il y a une
forme d'aberration à être à la à la
salle des quatre colonnes de l'Assemblée
nationale à aller voir le Figaro à leur
dire que ils ont raison la politique que
mène le gouvernement n'est pas une
politique de gauche et le soir à aller
distribuer des tractes avec nous parce
qu'on est sur la même liste aux
élections régionales donc ce sera une
double faute en période de campagne
de mais là il besoin de repère d'
d'abord ce budget est un budget que
j'assume totalement avec fierté comme
l'action que nous avons mené depuis 3
ans mais quand on est sur les mêmes
listes régional on a plutôt intérêt à ne
pas aller semer le doute par les
déclarations successives au fil d'une J
dans l'esprit de nos électeurs vous
parlez de scrutin est-ce que un jour
vous pourriez menacer par exemple les
frondeurs de bah tout simplement vous je
dis vous l'exécutif de ne pas leur
rcorder de de circonscription en 2017 si
jamais il continuent à à s'opposer à la
politique du gouvernement c'est c'est
une question qui sera réglée par le
parti mais c'est une question qui peut
se poser bien entendu il y a peut-être
un certain nombre d'endroits où elle
peut s'opposer déjà sur le terrain par
la réaction des militants et et bien
entendu que ces choses peuvent se poser
moi je souhaite toujours réunir mais à
l'évidence si un certain nombre de
députés ne votent pas le budget à 1 an
et demi des élections cette question
pourrait se poser oui une minute Jim ce
qui agace les les frondeurs c'est aussi
l'habitude qu' a prise le gouvernement
de modifier ses projets de loi alors que
son examen a débuté au Parlement ce fut
notamment le cas de la loi renseignement
club Bartelone cette semaine dans sa
conférence de presse de rentrée a
souhaité que l'exécutif s'interdise
d'amender ses propres textes est-ce que
vous y êtes favorable ça c'est pas c'est
pas une réaction des frondurs c'est une
réaction du groupe et c'est une
réactionut le que je porte au nom du
groupe qualité de la loi aujourd'hui
tient la capacité à la préparer en amont
et à ne pas voir arriver à la dernière
minute des articles additionnels qui
n'ont pas pu passer au Conseil d'État
qui n'ont pas pu passer ensuite le
filtre des examens en commission
concrètement comment on fait pour mettre
ça en place pour que le le gouvernement
puiss on travaille plus en amont
ensemble on nomme des rapporteurs à
l'Assemblée nationale plutôt et les
ministres ne s'autorisent pas à modifier
leur texte au dernier moment merci merci
le message